Sebastian copeland,
I a photographer,
a lecturer and an environmental
advocate,
jokingly referring to the age old
conflict between England and France.
And,
uh,
and my parents decided to challenge that
tradition and we're not very successful
at it.
So,
um,
I was,
my mother's British and my father's
French,
uh,
they separated and fairly early,
but luckily they've remained friends.
It was dysfunctional at first.
It's,
uh,
it's challenging at times for a child,
I think to be a bicultural,
uh,
but it pays off in spades later on in
life.
And so it has given me some tools to
deal with a,
with a variety and discrepancies between
cultures and,
and,
um,
and as it is now,
I consider myself to be,
try cultural because I've lived in
America for a,
an excessive 25 years with nothing.
Yeah.
25 years or so.
So it just,
it's great to be able to,
first of all,
I'm bilingual and helps and then,
uh,
then try cultural in the sense that I
can navigate between these different
countries and feel I'm either not
completely at home,
but certainly not completely a foreign
island.
My father is a,
a,
is a classical conductor.
And,
um,
there is a long family lineage in that,
a discipline.
My great uncle was a,
uh,
was a very famous pianist who was
Toscanini's favorite pianist.
And so I was brought up in,
in an environment of classical music
and,
uh,
which translated later on in jazz.
And then of course,
through my rebellious stage,
I translated,
uh,
not surprisingly,
I suppose,
in a,
in punk rock.
So I had a sort of a fairly broad,
a range of,
uh,
musical exposure and a,
until this day,
I consider music to come any into two
jars.
And that is
[inaudible].